this is just your friendly reminder that
you are not blessed you are privileged
not hashtag blessed hashtag privileged
so when you post pictures of your
beautiful vacation or your healthy
children or your loved blessed blessed
everything isn't a privilege these
people say non-stop focus on negative
energy and then they wonder why their
life is [ __ ] it is literally proven that
if you just call yourself a lucky person
you just become luckier so if you're I'm
blessed I thank God for my success I
really am so grateful for everything I
have they're [ __ ] on that you didn't
earn any of that you know what I mean
that wasn't there's no good energy there
you're privileged privileged it just all
comes to me I just wave my hands and my
opinions just just come and deliver
things unto me these people are sick in
the head Lee home and you write hashtag
bless you are offensive because because
you were not chosen as one of God's
favorites you were given opportunities
that other people were not including
access to and then you took those
opportunities we all have opportunities
yes some have better opportunities than
others but act on every opportunity you
have that takes you in the direction
that you want to go and you will get
there to being hashtag blessed you
spoiled little jealous brat hair a job
health insurance and there are many
people in this world who are oppressed
who do not have access or operations
favorite because you are better than
others you are privileged and that's
okay it just gives your privilege in a
positive way and remember that you are
not hashtag blessed you're not you just
changed my life a lot of
but a relationship between a man and a
woman is inherently unequal and that
goes for any relationship where someone
is deciding to date their oppressor just
like all white people have racism
brainwashed into them all males have
okay you know what I don't want to
listen to anybody who doesn't have their
their blinds straight she's got her
blinds are crooked okay she doesn't even
have her life together enough to have
her blinds even and normal okay no
you're you're white people are inanely
she's a slob is that not racist and then
you guys say that I'm crazy for saying
that there's an attack on white people
and half of the attack attack on white
people is from white people these people
are sick in the [ __ ] heads and I
don't know about who claims not to be a
massager fix your blind misogynist
self-aware
and any time that a woman decides to be
in a relationship with a man she's
making a sacrifice and a commitment
knowing that she's dating her oppressor
almost all women have sexual trauma and
emotional abuse trauma literally just
from society this is so sad so marrying
the man that sexually abused you yeah
maybe you're you know you're you're a
little nuts and you're with your
oppressor to use her language even
though I don't agree with it but then
going finding a nice guy over here he's
not impressing he's not oppressing you
go find somebody that lifts you up not
all men are oppressors this is so skeevy
to me that this girl actually dislikes
men so much that she would go out and
[ __ ] on everybody in the world who was
out there who is just happy in a in a in
a regular um straight heterosexual yeah
why why are you so upset about that is
it because no man ever wanted to date
you because you're a huge pain in the
ass and your house is sloppy come in the
blinds of crooked I'm out of there
taking a risk and being with you and
making a commitment to help you undo
your brainwashing now of course I'm not
saying that people shouldn't date the
opposite gender yes you are lack of
awareness can cause problems dummy there
is absolutely no reason why
hurricane Ida should have done that much
damage to Louisiana and Mississippi and
along the path that it's hurricanes
racist and part of the reason why is
because there is infrastructural and
environmental racism in a lot of
minority and low socioeconomic
communities okay first of all there's no
reason that the southern border of
Louisiana should still be struggling to
figure out what type of infrastructure
and Technology they can use to prevent
minority communities from being
destroyed and on top of that not just
being destroyed but also having to put
in their own resources to rebuild their
own community
like wake up and smell the flowers
people okay there is race embedded into
every decision in the United States of
America and the sooner that we realize
that the sooner we can stop people from
dying because of things that could have
been prevented remember in 1989 I know
you weren't allowed but uh there was
this massive massive earthquake in
California in San Francisco and Oakland
and a lot of people there were there
were I don't know how many people died
but a bunch of people died and it was
extremely destructive you know it it
affected a lot of white people so do you
think that hurricanes hate black people
and earthquakes hate white people in
this country tornadoes they don't hate
white people the thing is I understand
her point she's saying like I I
understand what she's trying to get
across she just does it in such a
terrible manner what's she trying to get
across please I think she's trying to
say how like those those neighborhoods
are poor but she's blaming it on like
she's blaming all right if you go to
like Southern Louisiana you know this is
like a lot of shitty neighborhoods and
most of it's like black people so she's
blaming that those neighborhoods just
not having as much like not recovering
as quick she's blaming it on racism them
having to put their own resources in
like plenty of white people and
hurricane
um the one that hit here like 10 years
ago just lost their homes they got
[ __ ] over like this happens in other
places you're you putting it about race
is just such a terrible analogy it's
it's it's such a crooked way of looking
at life I mean there is it does it does
beg okay it does beg an important
question of why haven't if if she's
correct and these communities have not
been rebuilt at the same
um do you know what I'm saying though I
do I do at the same Pace I'm just moving
it Forward at the same Pace as a white
Community because you talk about
Hurricane Sandy and uh a lot of those
communities say you know we knew a lot
of families you didn't but people I grew
up with uh in Breezy Point which was
devastated by uh the hurricane the water
surge the uh gas pipes busted and then
they were on top of it in the middle of
the hurricane there were massive massive
fires people died in the fires those
those houses have since been rebuilt and
people's lives to the best extent been
rebuilt because they were wealthier they
were a wealthier community so in a poor
Community if her question is asking why
haven't these places been rebuilt is it
racism or is it economics and exactly
and is it is it your uh is it your
elected officials like they got money
they got a lot of FEMA money what's what
they have and so so it's it it may
include some racism it may not but it's
far more complex than she's making it
it's not just [ __ ] racism like get
out of here that's people take no
personal accountability for anything
blaming everything on racism the reason
you're in that town and it doesn't get
fixed up on because they don't like
black people as much as such a terrible
way to look at life it's such a victim
mentality you know what I mean that's
that's just a terrible look something
that's been bothering me about the fact
that Texas restrictive abortion laws are
going in effect today is how a lot of
American journalists and you know
commentators are comparing this to the
Taliban and Sharia law and I just want
to push it on if you don't already know
this and you can't already clock it
Texas restrictive abortion laws this is
islamophobia what is going on with Texas
right now has nothing to do with the
racist Boogeyman that you've conjured up
in your mind and it has everything to do
with the fact that right-wing evangelism
caused this
that's it Point Blank period that was me
it has to do with the fact that white
people's birth rates are declining and
in a country where whiteness is power
that is a bad thing to them no no no no
it's about who you vote into office man
I want this white power white power
everyone's talking about give me this
give me some Power where's my white card
let me get some discounts here come on
they're they're blaming uh they're
calling you know Texas it's white power
it's all evangelism so the whole point
of this country is that we the people
elect representatives who go into the
state and the local state and federal
government and represent our values
right we vote in this one or this one
and in Texas there happened to be more
conservative people that are voting in
representatives for them for the people
who have these values that's that's
democracy pumpkin that's it if you want
to murder your baby up until the point
it's born go to New York sorry go to New
York get on a [ __ ] bus and I don't
know what to tell you I know you know if
you're poor it's not that easy but
actually there are resources there are
nonprofits that are paying to fly women
all over the country to transport women
whether some way in order to do it so
stop it has to do with holding on to the
systemic power they've had for so
systemic power they will do anything
including making sure that they harm
women and children
women and children they harm women and
children know they're saving children
you psycho to keep the status quo it has
to do with white supremacy they think oh
so stuck in The Matrix you don't even
see how it's so it's it's so funny they
think all the stuff that they're doing
is to to maintain white supremacy and so
white people have the advantage they
think that's like everything that the
government does and those people and the
elites is is to keep white people above
they think the elites are stupid enough
to to go off and think about race
non-stop she doesn't even consider that
she's the goofy one for going off and
talking about skin color all the time
such a mundane issue instead of a grand
scheme of things she is focusing on
building the Matrix Man so stuck in the
middle that's why this is happening
that's why this happening the Republican
Party built the Taliban army in
Afghanistan and they're currently
building the Taliban Army in Texas oh
let's hear it that's right the Texas
Taliban is terrorizing women in Texas
they're letting them know that if the
Taliban rape you and you get pregnant
you have to carry that terrorist baby
too oh my God they always go to this
point about the rate that's their one
point about abortion laws is is I wonder
if she's raped less than one percent
most of the time it's just people being
lazy and they're not using contraception
you know what I mean like why can't you
just use a condom or get on birth
control you're just you're letting Joe
Schmo pump crank one inside of you like
a dumbass and then you're just using
abortion as a contraception if a [ __ ]
Taliban guy comes to the US and gets you
pregnant you need to keep the baby these
people are horrible humans like look at
the scenarios they're pulling up there
and if you don't carry that terrorist
baby a term you can be serious baby ten
thousand dollars by the Taliban and I'm
guessing more than one Taliban Soldier
can sue you and the Taliban can sue not
only the person getting the abortion the
person driving them together so the
Taliban is actually a um an Arabic
organization so is she now is she now
being racist against Arabs by calling
American by calling Americans uh
jokingly calling them
yeah let's go let's play your game
pumpkin they can sue the doctor that
provides the abortion don't let them
build a Taliban Army in your state there
were Parts look at the problems these
people are worried about these are the
problems they're worried there were
Parts no you're you're not entirely
right sent you because there were parts
of the laws in Texas that were really
[ __ ] up so you could get a reward for
ratting on a woman who was having an
abortion okay you know what no now let's
not turn neighbor against neighbor yeah
I would agree you know it's not like you
know I there there are limits to
everything and you know over 60 of the
country here in America believes in
abortion at least up until you know the
first term or heartbeat right and then
it tapers off as as a pregnancy develops
uh how many people are in favor of
abortion so as a nation we are largely
accepting of it so to to turn around and
hit us against each other is is gross
and it was a shitty shitty piece of
legislation and I don't know if it held
out she's not entirely crazy probably
you know that that Texan officials
Taliban though
whatever well in every single election
every single one because the Republican
Taliban Army is coming I hope they come
for you
trust me
[Music]